five is heavier that Darvill air for a
blanket of applicants does adieu halt an
earlier incident around the 118 hi I'm
drew Carey here at the corner of sunset
and Highland in Los Angeles California
one of the worst intersections in all of
Los Angeles it's only quarter after 4:00
they already have a traffic cop in the
middle of the intersection directing
traffic he's here all the time traffic
goes all the way back in each direction
blocks of blocks there's no end in sight
to it
Los Angeles long a lot of other cities
like Portland San Francisco Minneapolis
you know traffic is the number one
concern number one complaint and then
the people live here and like a lot of
places in America it's only gonna get
worse so you live in LA right I do and
we think what the traffic here it's yeah
everyone in LA complains about traffic
but we didn't want to talk to just
anyone we wanted to talk to the poor
soul with the most congested commute in
LA we asked John and Ken from radio
station KFI am 640 for help so we teamed
up and threw in the recent foundation to
start the most congested commute here in
the LA area and you can't have a car
driving you there either I don't hear
from Harvey Weinstein about how bad is
commuted I hear people say this number
one reason they want to move that LA
traffic traffic yeah but you guys like
congestion because it keeps people
listening to your radio yeah really
admit that well we heard plenty of
traffic sob stories and finally found
our contest winner meet graphic artist
Josh lip King do this every morning
check out Sigler Google traffic every
day he kisses his wife goodbye you girl
and drives into hell
that's when you know get this heart
pumping in your chest start to sweat a
little and just kind of bite the bullet
just go for it but he tries to make the
most of the time he spends stuck in
traffic so this is a great little tool
one-hand flosser and it's slow enough
where you know people putting on their
makeup people shaving my chicken for
dinner last night you ever get tired of
the traffic in LA you can always take
the bus if you have a day and a half to
get to work I've used transit Josh
actually gave his car away and use
public transit for over a year but it
turned out the bus was even slower than
driving the transit out here is stuck in
the traffic so Josh eventually bought
another car Josh lives only 16 miles
from work but it often takes in an hour
and a half to get to the office at the
end of the day it's the same fight to
get back home three hours a day no one
should have to live like this we've got
to find a way to speed up Josh's commute
what would you do about traffic if you
were the king of Los Angeles so the king
of Los Angeles I think we're pretty much
screwed I've made people use the gas
pedal more and I make him pull all the
way up to the bumper phenomena on the
John and Ken show I suggested other ways
to bus congestion like letting private
companies pay for roads well first of
all taxpayers won't have to pay for the
road like I was talking to somebody from
The Reason Foundation at dinner and I go
what do you do something well it's like
the 101 itself and he goes just a
double-decker it and I go who's gonna
pay it's not a private company do it and
they can charge people to write on the
road and get a fast pass and you pay
five bucks sure the top that could be
for the yeah yeah but if you're
privatizing you have different companies
bidding you know what I would love to
own a freeway in LA maybe the Drew Carey
freeway would look something like this
snazzy double-deck toll road in Tampa
Florida
or maybe I'd build my road underground
here's a tunnel that's being built in
Paris tunnels that run underneath
Australian cities help people get around
town the private sector paid for all
these life would be much happier without
the congestion so let's build the josh
lifting tunnel double deck one of the
freeways he uses or hey how about
building some special
Express Lanes like the one accountant
Cedric Allen uses oh this piece of paper
this is the billing statement for using
the 91 express lane 168 total trips
valued at a cost of 548 dollars which
people see that and will go WOW you
spend that much the 91 Express Lanes
isn't your typical toll road a private
company built it in the middle of the 91
freeway in Orange County California the
Express lanes run right next to the
regular lanes so drivers can choose to
use them or not and you don't have to
stop a toll booth tolls are collected
electronically from this gadget that
hangs overhead when traffic gets bad the
price of the toll rises the octa owns
the 91 express lanes
here's spokesman Ted Nguyen the average
toll is about two dollars and 76 cents
the low end is about a dollar 50 and the
high end it's about 950 sounds pricey
but each day about forty thousand people
pay the toll because the special lanes
let them zoom past slow-moving traffic
mailman Demetrius Mike's battles through
congestion on his way home but once he
hits the express lanes his commute
speeds right up to me it seems you
brought hour and a half to two hours
traffic often keeps parents from picking
up kids at daycare on time imagine
paying five bucks for each minute you're
late Cedric knows all about that on an
average week we would probably spend
about forty dollars per child times
three that's 120 dollars a week for
being a few minutes like a hundred and
twenty dollars a week once he started
using the Express Lanes
Cedric almost never had to pay late fees
so paying a little can end up saving you
a lot
of money and time but with the extra
time I do my schoolwork
you know talk to my son this time to
relax have more time to prepare a decent
meal I have more time to spend with the
family and possibly even get in a movie
before going to bed at my unpredictable
traffic makes it hard for Josh to make
plans even with his wife but with an
express lane you could always make it
home in time for dinner the 91 toll
expressways I think that's a great idea
so let's see express lanes tunnels
double deckers anything else we could do
to get Josh home fast there has to be
some other way to travel like theirs
they should use the air use the air
hey man I'm true and I see you how are
you I may be ready for the easiest way
to work you ever had in your life yeah
let's go climb on and follow me the
helicopter doesn't crash
good less weird to show my funeral oh it
does
this is the way to go I gotta get get my
stuff set up to do this everyday your
traffic report Dan westbound Jesus bro
John chapter 12
that's so uh that was a blast huh
yeah exactly at the end of the day
Josh rode the chopper back home yeah so
long 90-minute commute my commute only
nine minutes I had no idea what it even
looked like in my neighborhood at 5:00
p.m.
gonna go inside have some dinner with my
wife it's the greatest thing thanks a
lot
such a happy ending or is it we can't
keep lying Josh to work so it's back to
the gridlock crying for him first thing
tomorrow
now we could build some Express Lanes
tunnels and double deckers taxpayers
wouldn't even have to pay for it then
Josh bus riders and other commuters
could escape congestion every day and
hey if we can be gridlock in LA we could
beat it anywhere the reason that TV I'm
drew Carey and I'm out of here